not win this game no but the other plan
was if San Antonio wins we're going to
have a chance to put Victor wiana on a
headset and there he is Victor thank you
very much for joining us on Inside the
NBA uh my pleasure man what did we just
see what a finish how how did it look
from where you
were wow I mean Calin just a a bully you
know Big Time still it's just it wasn't
our prettiest game but you know we're
learning every day and we're on the
right path
Victor sha here you're playing with a
young team and you're going to have
games like this you're going to win some
time you're going to lose some time how
patient are you before you think you
become uh become a championship
Contender how patient are you because
you know you are a great player but you
know how patient are you to where you
can say you know my team is ready for us
to continer championships that's what
you're here for to win championships you
don't want to be a l
exctly
ex straight bullet uh yeah you know how
patient I am as patient as we need to be
you know uh I'm just I'm I'm new here
I'm just learning you know I don't know
yet what it takes to win a championship
but I'm eager to find out and make the
sacrifices but you know the good thing
is I have total trust in my organization
and my coach so you know it's going to
take the time it's going to take well
you know I'm going pick it back on
Shaq's point he's saying you playing
with all those young guys like you're
all of 35 and you're only 19 so please
tell him you're 19 uh how has the
adjustment been with Coach papovich I've
watched your interviews with him you
said hey he's gotten on me a couple
times I personally think that's the best
thing happened to you how's that
relationship been so
far you know I I'm I agree with you you
know I I like to be with a coach that's
honest and that's you know that's going
to get into me and be relentless with me
and I don't got to worry about any of
this with Coach po you know I know he's
like that and uh you know it you know
right away on the first day of practice
you know he he showed that we're going
to be patient but we're not going to
lose any
time you know a Victor first
congratulation on the win but I just
remember last year my son KJ went to see
you play and he put you on FaceTime and
your dad got on FaceTime and he didn't
speak English so
culturally how different is it for you
being in he's like he's said Kenny my
English is just okay he didn't really
speak English well he brings French but
how culturally different you going from
France to San Antonio how's that
difference right now you know there
there are a lot of differences but um
it's hard to tell because ever since I I
came here was with the status of NBA
player you know with the top level
organizations yeah you know Word level
everything you know people taking care
care of me of my body of my habits you
know I've had so much help from the
Spurs not just for basketball but for
everything outside so it's I'm really in
a sort of comfort outside I'm in my off
the court life so I can give everything
on the court so it is way different you
know because in France I had to worry
about you know more stuff I had to go to
the grocery store sometimes now uh like
there's 10 people who would go to the
grocery stores for me if I needed to you
know so it's it is way different yeah uh
and just tell me what what nights like
this are like your your four games into
your NBA career uh but when you're on
the same floor with a guy who you've
watched hours and hours and hours of
tape on like a guy like Kevin Durant
what are these Knights like for you
Victor I mean he's K KD he's just like
in the highlights but uh everything
expected but you know it's it's what I
thought before even doing my first game
that every night is going to be special
in a way or another and yeah
sometimes there you know I want to think
like yo this is a guy that I've watched
for 10 years is like my idol but I got
to lock in and think yeah this is he's
going to try and step on me the whole
game so I got to step I got to lock in
and I don't care he's my idol I got to
go into them you know it was an amazing
comeback win 115 to 114 uh Tren Victor
was that was that was some night man and
thank you so much for taking a few
minutes hey hey Victor I got Victor I
got one final question how do you say
churro in French cherro what is that
churro you know what churro is you've
been in San San Antonio long enough it's
a dessert it's a dessert just ask what
it is the long the long
donut what never heard of that all
right people put me on that I we
apologize for the way that
that